Yeah.
Well the Jim Acosta one is strange because Jim Acosta,
like he wasn't supposed to be talking then.
Right,
right.
He was interrupting.
He was deciding that he was more important than the other person who was
talking.
Right.
And he was also decided that he was more important than everyone else in the
room.
And he's also deciding that having a White House press grandchild is a human
right.
So basically,
even though you could do it very well and you'll never be taken away,
but is there's gotta be some decorum.
Right.
Well,
their argument,
I would guess,
I can't speak for Jim Acosta cause I could speak in normal voice,
but their argument would be that because the president has made things,
so lack of decor and when she has therefore they're following suit.
So I guess that's real leadership,
but
this monster is really kicking in.
Yeah.
You like it though.
Yeah,
a lot.
A lot of stuff going on that cam
got the Tarin it says.
Yeah.
So yeah,
that's,
you know,
it's unfortunate.
I mean,
look,
I think I appreciate the fact that he goes out of his way to question the
Whitehouse narrative and he goes out of his way.
It's his job.
Yeah.
To,
to put the irons to the president and get them to answer questions.
But you can't do that while someone else is talking.
The other guy had the microphone.
You're the guy was supposed to be talking,
right.
Well,
this is why I think he's unforgivable because during the Singapore summit,
when you had president Trump and Kim Jong one from North Korea,
and they're making,
signing a piece of paper and they're trying to kind of hopefully go towards a
peaceful direction,
a cost that gets up and yells,
hey,
uh,
what about Ottawa?
I'm bear marshal,
Kim Jong and what?
I'm online beer.
It's like you got this guy who's got 25 million hearts dishes.
He's hauled off taking the first step that dropping his gun.
You're like,
Hey,
what about that kid you killed?
What about,
you know that it's a time and a place and I don't think Kim Jong Un's speaks
English.
I'm pretty sure he doesn't.
So,
uh,
I think the guy took wrestling a little too seriously.
Uh,
and,
and I don't know what it is.
I mean,
you know,
a lot of reporters,
I know that our pores,
they don't act like this.
No.
I think he likes attention and I think he feels like some,
there's something very significant about what he's doing.
And He,
I think he also wants to be a martyr.
He will wants to be a,
you know,
like every like,
he's got the weight of the world on his shoulders in,
but for him,
uh,
we'd be facing Nazi Germany.
Yeah.
It's,
it's the question is like,
when does someone get their press credentials removed from the White House?
When,
when can they no longer have Whitehouse credentials?
Like,
when is,
what is,
what do you,
what do you have to do to the point where everyone agrees you're a nuisance and
you were interrupting regularly.
CNN could just get someone else,
right.
Who's not going to scream out,
It's not like they're trying to block CNN and it's like they're saying to this
guy like,
you,
you are interrupting.
Like you're yelling things out.
And then what if everyone yelled things out at the same time?
Are you better than everyone else because you're not,
you're just a person here.
And if you just decide my opinion and my voice is more significant than anyone
else's,
well you,
you've thrown everybody else under the bus,
the entire rest of the room and the whole
process.
I remember Leslie Stahl had Trump on 60 minutes,
not that long ago,
and you know,
they're going back and forth and she goes,
well,
you know,
I don't want to talk about that.
I'm like,
this is the fucking president.
You're a reporter.
If he wants to talk about it,
at the very least it's going to be the president says x,
Y,
and z.
So who are you to be like?
And then I shut up.
We're not going to talk about this.
And he's like,
well fuck you.
I'm the president.
So I think there is,
I'm glad this is happening because I think for a long time the press who has had
an agenda since Washington's days as they should have an agenda,
pretend that they're honest and objective,
and they use the veneer of politeness and civility to be like,
look,
we're professional,
we're decent people.
But now the mask is dropping and you see that they're,
you know,
often lunatics.
Yeah.
I was watching this a piece on,
um,
God,
I really wish I remember what it was on,
but it was on,
um,
maybe I was listening to it either way it was on the news and when the news
started becoming an entertainment program versus when it was just,
here's the events of the day and this is,
you know,
this is what the,
the significance of these events could be and this is the impact it could have
on our society.
Instead,
it just became this really flamboyant Wilde crazy.
If it bleeds,
it leads and it became entertainment.
Right.
And they,
they,
they really nailed it down to 60 minutes.
There were saying when 60 minutes became a hugely successful financial show,
what's that?
A seventies then somewhere around there,
right when one 60 minutes,
it's been around for a long,
long time,
long,
long time.
But when 60 minutes became a hit,
it was a hit show,
like big advertiser money.
It was,
you know,
the entire country would watch it and then that sort of change the way they
viewed the news.
Cause now they viewed the news as a potentially profitable venture.
And then boy,
once they realized that people can clearly affiliate with one side versus
another side and they want that in their news coverage,
then you get the Weird Fox News slash CNN bias,
which is,
it is one of the weirdest polar like it distinctions.
If you watched the news,
you watch television during the elections particular anything that's really
significant going on,
you go back and forth between the two of them.
You're like,
are we,
there's like separate university.
Oh yeah.
Uh,
Scott Adams has that metaphor,
which is that we're looking at one movie screen and there's two movies in one
movie screen that different people see this exact same data and see different
conclusions.
And I think that's great.
I mean I think,
I don't think we need to be all United.
I think people should like what they like and the idea that we all got a great
and everything is to tell Terry aneurysm.
Yeah.
I mean
I definitely think that we should be able to enjoy what we enjoy and we should
lean whatever way we choose to lean.
I think the issue with the news though is when it's just straight up propaganda.
Yeah.
Like when is,
when,
is this actually the real objective version of the,
of the events or when are they deleting and editing stuff out and adding things
to it and concentrating on one maybe possibly thing,
but pumping it up to be more than it is because then it changes the narrative
for their side.
Uh,
this morning I went after some dimwit from Msa,
from,
excuse me,
from NBC and he goes,
this is the worst attack by the White House and the press freedoms in history.
I go,
John Adams,
second precedent put journalists in jail.
So did Lincoln Lincoln.
Of course you could say,
okay,
it's the civil war,
but there have been many cases of attacks on the press.
But of course because everyone's so narcissistic,
if it's happening to them,
it's the worst thing ever and this is basically the gulag.
Even though they can go on Twitter and have their hundreds thousand followers,
I have their good book deals as a consequence.
Is anybody criticizing Jim Acosta from the left?
Does anybody saying like hey,
you're not supposed to do that?
Like what you did,
what you did is out of line?
I haven't,
I have,
I've been having fun in La.
I have not seen that.
I think they have been running interference because I do think that the press
corps,
like any organization,
you work with someone side by side every day,
you're going to be friendly with them.
And I do think they,
there is very much obviously acrimony between Sarah Sanders and the White House
press corps and she's very insulting and hostile to them.
And you could say it's deserved or not.
So of course they're going to kind of team up together,
be like,
lady,
we're just trying to do our job and you're just spitting on our face every
single day.
Now the question is do these people have,
should have their faces spit it in or not?
Well I think they both suck.
No,
I think what she's doing sucks.
Like the way she treats people,
like some sheets,
some fucking school teacher in seventh grade.
That's,
that's what it seems like when Sarah is doing those,
those White House press things.
I love venom.
So I love that the venom is flowing right,
both directions and the Anti Leggett because I,
I think people get over politically by saying let's all get along.
And then people who don't get along or marginalized and those are the ones who
innovate things that the troublemakers are the ones who move culture and move
politics.
So whenever everyone gets together,
like,
oh,
90% of us agree,
then where it fits venom.
It's like,
yeah,
if this country has been at least two culture since the beginning and it only
stayed one because one conquer the other and held it under martial law for
decades,
there's no reason for us to be one United States.
Uh,
when everyone hates each other.
Like,
why?
Let's have a divorce.
What do you mean?
Like just if you want to separate out America to different parts.
I think everyone get along a lot nicer.
Do you mean like make separate country out of America really?
Of course.
Like Europe.
Like how,
like if you looked at the size of Europe and the relative size of countries and
how easy it is to travel from one country to another,
you can make a real honest comparison between Texas and New Jersey.
I mean,
they basically are different countries,
right?
I mean it's trickier because we all speak English.
So it seems like we're what but what are we United on?
And like,
why does this have to be this way?
Well,
because Texas,
we'll start invading everybody.
You can't just do that,
man.
They'll just throw,
they just steal New Mexico,
like whose garden it,
that's ours now.
And then they'll just
start marching their way through Phoenix and yeah,
it's a fucking disaster waiting to happen.
I think this is a disaster that's happening.
Oh yeah.
And I think the acrimony,
which I enjoy on some level because I think it's honest,
is going to get much worse.
Really.
What makes you think he's going to get worse?
Because I think both sides are just doubling down both sides left and right.
Yeah.
I very much doubling down the right has become radicalized as a function of
Trump.
The left has been radicalized for decades.
Uh,
and there's no look,
here's what happened with Kevin on hearings.
Either this very innocent family man has been railroaded completely by shameless
leftist or someone who is quite possibly rapist was nominated,
was put to the Supreme Court,
uh,
without being,
and everyone knows it.
So there's no in between.
And when you have one event and to completely obscenely different perspectives,
meeting each side sees the others obscene,
I don't see where you get together.